and MCU favorite is relieved to start
his next chapter and it appears he's not
alone so what does this say about the
impact being a Marvel star has on the
Studio's stable of performers at this
point it kind of feels like every single
actor on the planet has appeared or it's
said to appear in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that's said there have been
actors who have elected to step out of
the MCU Spotlight and move on to other
projects when Robert Downey Jr and Chris
Evans two of the original Avengers were
faced with expiring contracts both chose
to exit the Cinematic Universe entirely
now a newer MCU star is opening up about
his decision to leave this universe
behind and it may just indicate that
there are larger problems at play in the
MCU will you make a choice after years
in the wrestling world Dave Batista
started appearing on the big screen in
2011 in projects like House of the
Rising Sun but it's his role as dragster
destroyer in the Guardians of the Galaxy
films that put him on the map where the
third Guardians movie in the can and
Batista's room appearances in Glass
Onion and dune putting a spotlight on
his very real acting jobs the wrestler
turned actor wants to put drugs in the
rear view Batista recently told GQ I'm
so grateful for Drax I love him but
there's a relief it wasn't all Pleasant
it was hard playing that role the makeup
process was beating me down and I just
don't know if I want drags to be my
legacy it's a silly performance and I
want to do more dramatic stuff from
there he recounted an anecdote about
showing glastonian to his fellow actors
on June part 2 and feeling nervous until
Oscar winner Javier bardham literally
embraced him a sweet gesture Batista
called surreal
anyone who's seen glastonian or is
excited for Batista's upcoming lead in M
Night shyamalan's knock at the cabin
knows that Batista's acting Talent
certainly extends beyond the extremely
literal-minded and often murderous
tracks that's when you
why would I put my finger on his throat
but the real question is this is Batista
speaking to a larger Point whether it's
due to constructing makeup contracts or
story lines I have to go a specific way
in order to fit into a larger framework
it stands to reason that the Marvel
Cinematic Universe can stifle and act as
overall creativity performers like Chris
Evans have stretched their creative
muscles he's making his Broadway debut
in lobby hero and will play Gene Kelly
in an upcoming biopic some actors like
Natalie Portman were so dismayed with
their MCU turns that they left part way
through their storylines though famously
Portman returned to collaborate with
daika ytt on Thor love and thunder even
current MCU standbys like Elizabeth
Olsen it was played one to maximoff
since before she officially earned a
moniker as a Scarlet Witch have
expressed dismay at the Stranglehold
Marvel has on an actor's career in a
2022 interview at the New York Times
Olson said the MCU has prevented her
from taking jobs in smaller Indie movies
revealing the MCU took me away from the
physical ability to do certain jobs that
I thought were more aligned with the
things I enjoyed as an audience member
and this is me being the most honest
Marvel might provide a steady paycheck
and worldwide Fame but it can also
stymie a performer in their Prime Martin
scorsetti famously compared superhero
movies to theme parks and it stands to
reason that after a while some of these
actors might want to head home
[Music]